Virtual production is commonly thought of as an umbrella term that encompasses a wide
range of technologies and digital production techniques.
It's also directly associated with a set of technologies known as in-camera visual effects.
Here practical content is married directly to digital content on a physical stage using
an LED volume.
This form of virtual production allows directors to view and interact with virtual environments
and characters in real time.
Through the use of Unreal Engine, virtual production allows for some interesting tool sets, including
smart animation construction tools such as Sequencer, iPad-based virtual cameras or VCAMs,
a data recording tool set known as Take Recorder, LiveLank, data transmission protocols, remote
API, performance capture, and ARKit face tracking.
There are also workflows enabling real-time editing and scouting, which allows multiple
users to manipulate the scene in real-time.
Combined with VR scouting-based tools, directors have the opportunity to examine the virtual
world in headset.
Finally, Unreal provides an all-in-one solution by recording, editing, and integrating post-production
inside of Unreal Engine, thus reducing the need for external 2D and 3D applications.